and he'll be talking about imitation
learning the structure addiction yeah
okay so thanks for coming thanks to the
organizers for inviting me and doing all
the organizing and stuff like that so
I'm going to talk about structured
prediction stuff which is basically what
I do so I'm a natural language
processing guy like at heart and I think
to a large degree natural language
processing really is the field of
structured prediction like it's
something that we've been studying since
I don't know the 60s or something like
that with finite state methods and stuff
like that so that was sort of the the
culture that I grew up in but I think
things have changed a lot and so I want
to talk about sort of this relationship
between imitation learning in structured
prediction but just to like make sure
we're all on the same page I want to
start out with some example of the
structured prediction and so I might go
back and forth between calling it
structured prediction and joint
prediction where I'm really just trying
to predict a bunch of variables that are
correlated and I want to predict them
sort of to optimize some joint loss or
something like that
so probably the classic example of
structured prediction of sequence
wavelengths you get an input like the
monster ate a sandwich and you want to
assign like part of speech tags to the
sentence you also have things like named
entity recognition that look very
similar I'll do actually I travel
directly on Monday not yesterday but you
also have other sequency like problems
like this is a DNA spliced site
prediction problem where you have DNA
sequences and you're trying to separate
them into say like introns and exons
right so these are all sort of sequence
e problems they're also more like
tree-like problems so in NLP we love
parsing so this is a particular part in
formalism called dependency parsing
where you try to draw a tree over the
words of a sentence to explain their
syntactic structure there are other
problems like in computer vision where
you might get like a 3d point cloud of
voxels
and you're trying to label them as to
like what's a tree and what's ground and
what's building and stuff like that so
like what do these things have to do
with each other while we're trying to
predict
the values of multiple variables
simultaneously and we believe that
there's some like correlation among them
so in language land we might believe the
determiners precede nouns in English or
the sentences have verbs and we might
want to express these as like features
in our model it could also be because I
have a lot function that forces me to
pay attention to structure so the
example I like for this is like I don't
know I might be teaching a bunch of
undergrads and maybe in the first half
of class like when I teach AI the first
type of class is basically like
graphical model stuff in the second half
is basically reinforcement learning
stuff and I'm going to give them an exam
at the end of class and it's going to
cover both parts and there could be two
ways I score this exam so way a is your
score on the exam of your average across
these two parts that would be like the
normal thing to do maybe is your score
on the exam is the max of your score on
these two parts all right and so if I
tell you that your loss function is a
you're going to sort of study everything
equally but if I tell you your loss
function is B you're going to decide
which is easier and you're just going to
study that half and so this doesn't
actually require the two things to be
correlated right it could be the first
half was on reinforcement learning the
second half was on like ancient pottery
but because of how I've set up the last
function you want to pay attention to
the fact that there's interaction among
these variables in terms of how you're
being evaluated so what's a classic way
of sort of solving these things the
classic way is basically a graphical
model like things to CRF structured svms
and so on so we have some input X we
have some candidate output Y and we're
going to score this thing using like a
linear function or nowadays you're going
to score it using a neural network so
the way that you define features here is
you define a Markov random field and
there are lots of things that make this
hard so how do you deal with like loopy
structures so if you're in like a loopy
BP typesetting what else it can be slow
to do inference in these models and in
order to get these things to train you
need to sort of assume that the lot
decomposes
for the same structure that your
features decompose over and in the MRF
so this is like my sort of hand wavy
model of how like the classic approach
works so we're going to learn this score
function the designs of fidelity to
input-output pairs so good pairs should
should get a high score and then a test
time I get some input and I have to
solve this Arg max problem of finding
the output that maximizes that score so
this is some sort of combinatorial
optimization problem under like super
restrictive assumptions you can solve it
exactly often with dynamic programming
or some form of integer linear
programming but in most cases you can't
and you have to do some heuristic search
and this is kind of unfortunate so at
the end of the day these things are
really so actually I'm gonna skip this
example so at the end of the day these
things are really slow so why is this so
if you're talking about parsing the
number of trees you could possibly
output as exponential in the length of
the input if you're trying to do
translation say from a foreign language
into English the number of possible
translations is also exponential on the
size of the input same thing if you're
trying to do summarization so pretty
much anything you want to do the number
of output structures is going to be
exponential on the size of the input in
some way and so you can sort of hope
that maybe you do dynamic programming so
this works if your features are simple
so if you're in a sequence labeling land
if you assume like Markov features so
things only depend on their neighbors
you can do dynamic programming if you're
in a tree space like parsing if you
assume like context-free miss you can do
dynamic programming but I think that one
thing that like the past I don't know my
whole life as a researcher has taught me
is that getting better features is
really a good idea even if it comes at
the cost of making inference harder and
so I'm really not willing to give up on
good features even if it means I give up
on on say my favorite dynamic
programming algorithms and then the
other thing that's often buried in these
sort of results is that like yes parsing
under a context-free assumption is cubic
length of the sentence but there's also
the grammar constant that sits out front
and often this grammar is huge and it's
often like the dominant cost in like
real implementations of parsing
algorithms so that's sort of my like
whatever five minute background on what
instruction prediction lies hard so I'm
going to talk basically about three
related but not super interconnected
problems so the first thing I'll talk
about is the structure prediction
there's imitation learning which is
going to sort of set the framework to
talk about this hidden expense of
features and then finally I'll talk
about learning under bandit feedback so
that's the structure you should
interrupt me at any time that
something's not clear okay so we have
this structure prediction problem right
so we have some input X we at training
time we have some ground truth Y it
belonged to a set of a very large set of
possible y's for this for this input we
have I guess I have pictures of this so
I have an input like item Kanak an the
ground truth is pronoun little verb
determiner noun I have the giant set of
possible outputs
I have something maybe that my model is
predicting which I'm going to call Y hat
I have a loss function which tells me
for some ground truth Y and some
predicted Y hat how good am i doing and
then like usual I have data sampled from
from some distribution and so you know
like most things the goal is to find
some predictor that produces outputs
that belong to the correct output set so
for instance if I'm trying to predict
Trine's the thing that comes out had
better be a tree and I want to minimize
my expected loss on on future data by
learning this function age based on my
samples all right so the way that we're
going to do this which is like very
different from sort of the Markov random
field approach is to decompose things
into a sequence of decisions so
how you do this is sort of your choice
the way you know the most standard sort
of obvious thing for a sequence labeling
task is to go left to right over the
input so I have something like I I have
a decision point I choose an action like
pronoun then I have can and I have
another decision point I choose an
action like Moodle and then I proceed
through the sentence and then at the end
I get to this final state and I can look
back at my path and from this path I can
extract my full output and then that
saying I can score with my loss function
all right good okay yeah so that's what
I just said okay so we're going to talk
about this in terms of policies because
this starts to look a lot like
reinforcement learning
so in general policy is going to be a
function that I'll call Pi which maps
observations to actions so the
observations can be the full input so
the sentence I'm trying to tag the time
step I'm at the previous decisions that
I've made so I can include all of them
and basically anything else I want as
long as it's not from the future right
it can only be from the past and then
this thing is going to choose an action
which is going to guide me through this
this decision process okay so I'm going
to now switch to this analogy for plane
Mario because this is a good imitation
learning example so here we have Mario
we're going to extract features from a
grid around Mario and then we're going
to map this to one of two to the fourth
possible output so this is the buttons
that you're pushing on the controller
and the key thing that I'm going to
assume is that I have access to an
expert and I can watch this expert play
a bunch of times and I can try to mimic
their behavior so the analogy here to
the structure prediction case is that in
the structure prediction case a training
time I have ground truth outputs from
which I can reverse engineer may be an
optimal sequence of actions so here's an
example of an expert plane Mario so this
is a step on Ross made this video it's
very nice so the expert is very good
this expert is actually just a like
breadth first search algorithm so it's
like very very
it's way better than any person would
ever be at playing Mario okay so we have
training data that looks like this and
so the obvious thing that you can do is
is train a car oh so now I'm switching
from Mario to cars sorry so I can't draw
Mario I can draw cars right so I can
look at the trajectory that the expert
took and I can construct a data set
where I have the states that the expert
visited or the observations at each
point in time paired with the action
that the expert took so I'm going to
call the expert the reference so now I
can train a classifier on this data set
so okay so does this work
john knows the answer
it's 50/50
okay I will show a video and then you'll
tell me oh and then we're gonna let pie
play right okay so here's what happens
when you do this
okay so does not work so why doesn't it
work right and so in particular why does
Mario get stuck behind the pipe petegem
work yeah so the expert never got into
the situation where they were right next
to a pipe and so like Mario learned that
in general it's good to run right and so
he's like well I'm just going to keep
running right even though I'm stuck next
to this pipe right so we somehow want to
be able to learn to recover from our
errors okay so I have this like nice
analogy to kittens so I see that machine
learning people like kittens it's like
half of the deep learning papers are
about kittens but there are other
kittens from 1936 so there's this nice
paper by Helden Hine studying two
kittens so they took kittens there was
they put them in this little box and one
of the kittens could walk around and
then the other kitten their actions were
constrained by the action of the first
kitten right so the first kitten is
basically controlling the second kitten
okay so they're seeing exactly the same
thing and then you basically look at how
they learn about the environment and the
helden hind result is that this kitten
ends up awesome at interacting with
their environment this kitten which sees
exactly the same things to not learn to
interact with their environment at all
so somehow like actually interacting
with the environment seems important at
least for kitten learning and so maybe
it's also important for I was going to
say human learning but machine learning
okay so so how are we going to try to
get around this so we're going to try to
learn to recover from errors so we're
going to start off the same way we let
the expert drive the car we collect a
data set exactly the same way we did
before we train this pup we train a
policy which I'll now call pi-1 on this
data set and now we're going to let pi-1
drive the car right so PI 1 is now
getting stuck next to pipes or whatever
error it is that PI 1 makes and now
we're going to ask the expert at every
state visited by PI 1 what action would
you take in order to recover from that
error so you should think of this as
well
I have this poor person sitting in a car
that's driving itself and the person is
like frantically trying to steer the car
back onto the road where the car is
ignoring what they're saying but it's
recording their actions so that we can
learn to recover from errors so this
gives us a new data set which we'll call
v1 we take the union of these two data
sets we train a new policy and then we
run pi/2 we collect expert actions on
pi/2 and we repeat this process all
right so this algorithm is called dagger
it's like one of my favorite algorithms
it's it has a nice result that basecoat
it's not my algorithm so I can say it's
my favorite algorithm so it has this
nice result that basically like I mean
the sort of hand wave over the the exact
details but basically what we say is if
the classifier for predicting the
actions may has an error rate of Epsilon
then the total loss of the policy is
going to be bounded by something like T
times epsilon plus a little constant so
the reason you should be impressed with
this is because it essentially means
there's no compounding error so I'm
making T many decisions on each decision
I suffer epsilon error and so the best I
could really possibly hope for is T
times epsilon and I'm basically getting
this plus a small constant right to the
supervisor algorithm that doesn't work
they get stuck next to a pipe you get
something like T squared epsilon and
that's because of compounding error okay
so so does this work yeah it works a lot
better than than supervised learning you
know I can show you curves rather than
videos but videos are more interesting
so it's not perfect but it doesn't have
these degenerate problems like getting
stuck next to pipes
okay so we took I thought this was going
to end by now
it will end eventually so so we take the
same idea and we apply it instead of two
plane Mario - doing sort of structured
prediction tasks so I'm going to go over
the structure please be done okay I'm
going to go over the structure one
variable at a time and I'm going to
predict each one but importantly a
training time I'm training to recover
from my previous errors so that if I get
off path I don't lose
so does this work it actually works
quite well so this was a paper we had it
nips last year although I think it was
first rejected from nips 2014 so it's
like a little bit out of date but
basically this is comparing the
imitation learning style algorithms to
more classic algorithms like conditional
random field structure predict
structured perceptron and structured SVM
with varying training algorithms and so
here the the x-axis is the amount of
time that it takes to Train y-axis is
accuracy on test data so this is what
you get if you ignore structure so you
just make every prediction independently
so you train very quickly but you
plateau pretty pretty low if you do the
imitation learning stuff then after
about 10 minutes this is on a million
words of training data so after about 10
minutes you have basically what was at
the time of state-of-the-art part of
speech tagger and was substantially
faster than say various implementations
of CRFs which I guess are here and here
and also structure of SVM and stuff like
that so I think the main results here
was that we get something that trained
super fast because we don't have to do
like belief propagation or dynamic
programming the training time and it
also works really well because it learns
to sort of recover from its own errors
oh yeah
several iterations yeah so the one thing
that I guess I'm hiding from you here is
that the algorithm that I described was
really very batchi but the algorithm
we're using here is much more online so
what we're doing here is well you can
basically just think of it as a batch
size of one so we get a single training
example we run the current learned
policy on that example and collect the
corrections at each point in time and
then do an online update to that policy
yeah oh yeah so I that's a really good
point I should have had a slide for this
so the corrections are algorithmic so
the the setup is basically I'm at some
estate I wish I had a oh there's a board
that's awesome yeah so I've gone along
for a while and I get to some state s
and then what I'm trying to compute is
PI R F of s but it gets to cheat and it
gets to look at the ground truth because
it's training time and so this should be
the action that if I took that action
and then played out the rest of time
optimally would minimize the long-term
loss so it's not very pleasant how to
write this but we want to minimize the
loss from the truth to this predicted y
hat where Y hat is reached from s right
so we want to sort of roll out to the
end until we have some loss awesome and
so for most not for most for many loss
functions you can do this in closed form
and it's convenient okay so you can oh
the other thing that's nice is we had
this nice way of like writing code for
this if you want to play around and
write your own struck
prediction problems you can do this very
easily so this was the the version that
was in the newspaper last year that we
also had results on named entity
recognition and dependency parsing and
they look sort of qualitatively the same
it's also very fast at test time so now
everyone might be sitting there like but
like how what about neural networks so
everyone does neural networks these days
so I think one thing that's actually
quite interesting is that this like
sequential prediction view of structured
prediction is essentially the standard
view and neural nets land so people who
do structured prediction with neural
nets they basically decode with
recurrent neural networks which look
exactly like make a prediction given a
state move to a new state make a
prediction given a state route in your
state so it's exactly the same model if
you want to play around with it so we
built this this thing called masa eco
which is built on top of pi torch so it
completely separates tasks like part of
speech tagging from the neural network
features you want to implement from the
learning algorithm like dagger or
maximum likelihood or reinforced or
anything like that so this is with Tim
who's at Hopkins it's not actually out
yet but it'll be out soon so if you
don't want to worry about tasks and
they're all net features when you have
some new imitation learning algorithm
you want to try out on like a battery of
NLP problem this should make your life
very easy all right so that was the
first part so I want to talk so that's
sort of addressing this question of oh
yeah John to go to no little work only
to their duties are kind of carrying
over a lot of internal state from step
yeah this is being handled here yep
it's so the thing that's tricky is to
figure out how to do the backpropagation
right not totally trivial oh and if in
case you're wondering so MA so do you go
is Portuguese for blowtorch okay anyway
I also learned that you're not allowed
to have Cydia zin URLs so please don't
call it maca Rico even though that's
what it looks like okay so I so this
part is really addressing this
computational problem of making
structured prediction efficiently sort
of from the algorithmic perspective
there's another reason that structured
prediction is often expensive and that's
because features are expensive and so
what I'm going to talk about here is
basically trying to get around the fact
that computing features and structured
prediction models can often be like a
huge bottleneck in terms of computation
so here's sort of the view that we had
so this is how like NLP works so we get
some training data we go talk to people
in this room and they tell us what their
favorite learning algorithm is and we
train and we get a slow predictor so
we're not very happy with that we spend
a bunch of time building some heuristics
like a star heuristics or something like
that to try to make this fast and so
what we were really trying to do is glue
all of these things together into one
piece that's just the learning algorithm
right so basically like can we learn to
both be accurate and efficient right so
there's the quality measure that we care
about care about is some trade-off
between speed and accuracy so I'm going
to give an example from dependency
parsing so we have a sentence like NLP
algorithm we do the kitchen sink of
features we're trying to construct a
tree that says for instance that use is
the head verb of this sentence it has a
subject which is algorithms and as an
object which is sink and then the rest
of the tree sort of build out from there
so how do people or what is one way that
people do this so one way that people do
this is they think of it as a minimum
spanning tree problem so we have a big
graph that's fully connected
there's a unique node which is the root
and otherwise all of the nodes or words
in the sentence and there should be
actually there we go there are the words
and so any directed spanning tree of
this graph corresponds to a parse tree
of the sentence so in particular that's
the that's the gold-standard tree okay
so how does learning work here so we
throw a bunch of features on the edges
or if we're in neural nets land we let a
neural net build up features on the
edges and then this will give us an edge
weight for every edge in the graph where
depending on whether you're minimizing
or maximizing large weight edges are
good and small weight edges are bad so
if you actually want to run this a test
time the first thing you do is you
compute some part of speech tags the
next thing you do is for every pair of
words in the sentence you compute some
features that talk about how related
those two words are and any R undirected
MST so it turns out that running
directed MST is actually quite fast and
the computing features is way way slow
in these problems so this is sentient
planks versus time so the blue bar is
how long does it take to do the part of
speech tagging that's quite fast
the yellow is once you have all the
features how long does it take to run
directed MST that's also very fast and
then the orange is how long does it take
to compute these pairwise features
between every word and that's incredibly
slow so this is an average length
sentence and for that average length
sentence something like 300 times as
much time is being spent computing
features as running MST so this sort of
suggests that like you know going out
and finding better MST algorithms is not
going to make this much better we really
need to get this bar down so how do we
do this so basically what we want to do
is we want to only compute features that
are actually useful for predicting the
final tree right so they're going to be
lots of features that don't really
contribute
but we don't want to do like offline
feature selection because we want to be
able to like choose more features on
edges that are hard and choose fewer
features on edges that are easy and I'll
show you later that that actually helps
so the way then we're going to do this
is we're going to start off with a graph
that has almost no features on it and
based on this graph which should be easy
to or should be efficient to construct
I'm going to run my my parser alright so
this is basically a free operation this
is going to produce some parse tree of
this sentence so now I'm going to go
through every edge in this parse tree
and I'm going to decide do I want to
lock that edge like do I believe that
that edge is correct or should I leave
it as sort of like I'm not sure okay so
for instance I might so this is going to
be done by a classifier my classifier
might be sure that this edge is correct
but unsure about the rest of the blue
edges so sides note it's super important
that you only look at the blue edges and
not every edge if you look at every edge
you're now pane and squared and you lose
so the reason why you want to run the
parts are over and over again is so that
you only look at a subset of the output
at each step okay so now for all of the
non locked edges we add so we throw out
ones that are inconsistent with this
edge and then for all of the remaining
edges we add some more features
okay so then we run our parser again it
produces a different tree we lock some
of the edges oops I thought there's more
animation we lock some more of the edges
and then when every edge is determined
or when we when we've exhausted all of
the features we stop all right so does
the algorithm make sense okay so this is
basically a control problem and I've
already told you how to solve control
problems you run dagger so we run to
actually run a small variant of dagger
that we call coaching but it doesn't
really matter you basically run dagger
on this problem to learn how to control
this
this edge locking mechanism so the first
thing we looked at was how does this
compare to static feature selection
right so I'm just going to decide ahead
of times which features I'm going to
compute on all edges and then always
compute those features versus doing it
dynamically as you build up the tree and
so here on the x-axis we have run time
on the y-axis we have accuracy and so
yeah it's better to do it dynamically so
the other thing that's kind of
interesting is looking at what actually
happens over time so I there are a bunch
of lines in this graph but so the x-axis
is how many features that we added so
far and then the y-axis is going to vary
depending on what line we're looking at
okay so the gray line is how many edges
remain and so the first thing that sort
of happens is that this drops off
quickly which means that lots of easy
edges are being locked in quickly the
second thing that's interesting is that
[Music]
let's see what's the right way to say
this there are edges that stick around
until the end because I'm very unsure
about them and adding those features
does actually help resolve them alright
so the message is that for easy edges
you don't need many features and you can
win there for hard edges you actually do
need all the features and you can still
win there okay so if you are a parsing
crowd you would want to know what my
unlabeled attachment accuracy scores are
I think people here maybe don't care so
much but basically the thing that you
want to look at is the baseline which is
the ugly yellow color and our thing
which is green and this is over a bunch
of different languages
and so sometimes we're better than not
doing a feature selection sometimes
we're worse than not doing a feature
selection but the y-axis is like super
squished so really it doesn't make a
huge difference like
we don't do better or worse at parsing
we just get faster in terms of speed so
on English this is all normalized to one
so on English we're about five and a
half times faster than the baseline for
Chinese were not really that much faster
the blue bar is this vine pruning
algorithm by sasha rush which is quite
different but it was sort of the obvious
competitor at the time okay so I told
you this story for dependency parsing
but you can actually do this for almost
any algorithm where you have some
prediction tasks that's making internal
decisions that you want to control so we
all did this for for ILP s so a lot of
structured prediction problems you can
write down as integer linear programs or
actually probably all of them you can
write down as integer linear programs
and then you can solve those using like
branch and bound or something like that
so I will not explain how branch and
bound works the important thing is that
you're basically exploring the search
tree and you're maintaining little
bounds on the values at each point in
the search tree and you want to prune
edges and explore the tree in an
interesting way and so if you look at
like a well-engineered ILP solvers like
grow B or C Plex or something like that
they have like decades of human effort
into designing heuristics for when to
prune parts of the tree what parts of
the tree to explore next and so on and
so we can apply basically the same idea
to exploring the aisle that sorry which
is exploring the branch and bound tree
as we apply to exploring the the
dependency parsing tree yeah so that's
that's basically what I said so I think
I will just tell you the take home story
so we compared against Grove E which if
people haven't used Grove E is awesome
unless you're trying to beat it and then
you hate it because it's actually really
really hard to beat
so I
[Music]
depending on the problem that we were
looking at we could either get
essentially zero improvement or like
reasonably substantial improvement over
overgrow V speed but I think like you
know one point five percent better
doesn't sound that great but getting any
improvement at all was like a major
uphill battle grow V is like super super
well engineered okay so so you can do
this for lots of problems and now
basically anything that you can cast as
an ILP you can use this same idea to try
to speed up all right so very good for
that all right the last thing I will not
use dagger here so this will be the non
dagger part of the talk so I want to
talk about structured prediction under
bandit feedback there are supposed to be
edges here but okay so what's the setup
so I'm like some webpage and when
someone goes to my web page I have to
decide like what stories do I want to
display how do I want to orient them on
the web page what size font do I want to
use what color do I want to use what
images do I want to use and so on right
so I have this big design problem and
I'd like to learn to make better designs
based on looking at user behavior so I'm
going to think of this design problem as
a structured prediction task right so I
have a bunch of variables that I'm
trying to predict and once I've made
predictions for them I have some web
page layout software that's going to
generate a web page for me and so I want
to pick those variables to optimize some
like user metric the important thing and
the thing that's different from
everything I've talked about so far is
that I only get to try once right so
like someone goes to like Lomond I don't
get to say like here are ten thousand
ways I could have laid out this webpage
which one do you like best right so I
get to show them one and I get to see
like hey do they stick around my web
page or not or however I'm measuring for
for months so this is very much like a
bandit feedback like problem the role
gives me a context which is like the
user who came to my webpage I have to
make a prediction over a bunch of
variables and then this gets shown to
the user and the user gives me some
reward and then tomorrow some new user
comes okay so this is structured
contextual bandit so how does this
compare to sort of the the structured
prediction case so we're going to think
about the states the search space in
exactly the same way so we have a bunch
of variables we're making decisions or
exploring the space the feedback is very
different so before we get full labels
from which we can play games like this
here we just get to make a single
prediction and collect a single loss so
traditionally in sort of the structured
prediction view of the world we assume
that our reference is optimal so in
particular I can solve this problem
optimally this is definitely not going
to be true in the webpage design tasks
on the webpage design tasks there's some
software that's running on Lamond right
now and it may be good it may be bad who
knows but i would actually like to
improve on it right so like if all i
give you at the end of the day is
something that's like not much worse
than the reference this is like not so
useful to me the reference is only
available at training time in the the
supervised case in the contextual bandit
case we're going to assume it's
available both the training time and
testing times I can always run the
off-the-shelf algorithm and so like I
said the goal is sort of very different
so in the structured prediction setting
the goal is to imitate the expert to
imitate this thing but in the contextual
bandit case the goal is to improve on it
right so and I said this before but
existing algorithms like dagger can give
you a result that like your loss is not
much worse than the loss of the
reference but this is not useful in the
contextual bandit setting
okay so there are two things we need to
do so we need to be able to learn a
policy that improves on rep and then we
need to be able to do this under partial
feedback so I'm going to spend most of
the remaining like five minutes talking
about this first one and then I'll just
sort of hand wave on the second one okay
so one question is what do I want to do
I so trying to figure this out is kind
of tricky so we would like to still be
competitive with the reference so if the
like current webpage layout on Lomond is
optimal I'd like to still be optimal all
right so that's certainly something that
I would like maybe I would also like
some notion of global ops sorry of local
okay I would really like global
optimality I will tell you now you're
not going to get it so I might prefer or
I might like some form of local
optimality the notion of local
optimality we'll use is that we compete
with our own one step deviations which
basically means if Green is the
decisions that my current policy takes
then a one step deviation of Green is
something that makes one decision
differently from how Green does and I
would like Green to be locally optimal
in this neighborhood okay all right so
we're going to think about three things
in our algorithm so we're going to have
a role in phase and then we're going to
try some sort of deviation and then
we're going to have a roll out phase so
the main thing that matters is that how
we roll in affects the distribution of
states that we train on right so this is
like the Mario getting stuck next to a
pipe case the rollout affects how we
score actions right so I'm at some state
I have a bunch of actions available to
me which one is best depends not just on
that action but everything I do in the
future from there and so
rollout affects how we get scores okay
so the first thing we did was sort of I
guess a bunch of like lower bound II
like things so it looked at different
ways that you can do roll in and roll
out so you can roll in with the
reference policy so this is like getting
stuck next to a pipe you can roll in
with a learned policy that's much more
like dagger you can roll out with the
reference policy you can roll out with
the learned policy and you can roll out
with like a 50/50 mixture of the two so
if you roll in with ref you get an
inconsistent algorithm you basically
this is revisit you get stuck next to
pipes so yeah I mean why does this
happen I mean it basically happens
because the states that you're trained
on are not representative of states that
you test on so if you roll in learn and
then roll out with reference then I
can't guarantee that you get local
optimality and basically the reason why
is because if if ref is not realizable
then rolling out with ref might bite
might be sort of overly optimistic right
you might think like oh I can get there
if only I take this action but then you
actually can't learn to to sort of
follow the right path
if you roll in learn and roll out learn
you're not using rep at all and you're
just doing reinforcement learning and
reinforcement learning is hard and so we
don't want to do that and so it turns
out that rolling in with the learned
policy in rolling out 50/50 is actually
a pretty good thing to do so we call
this particular algorithm walls so the
main result that we get is that if you
run this training procedure the regret
of the learned policy is bounded by the
sum of these two terms so the first is
basically sorry let me say that
differently so these two terms are small
so
so the first term is what's your regret
with respect to the reference and the
second term is what's your regret with
respect to your own one-step deviations
and so we would sort of like both of
these to be small simultaneously we
don't have that we have the sum is small
so there are a couple of things that
fall out of this so the first is this
term is always non-negative which means
that this term is always small which
means that we're guaranteed to compete
with ref so that's good the second thing
is that if ref is already optimal then
this is non negative and this means that
the red term is small which means that
we're locally optimal and then the third
thing is that if ref is suboptimal which
is the case that we care about then one
of two things happens either
we're locally optimal or we're better
than ref and so this is not like super
clean but basically the result is that
in the case that we care about we either
improve substantially on the initial
policy or we're at least locally optimal
okay so getting an exact local
optimality pard I won't talk about that
doesn't work in practice yes it works in
practice no one wants to know results
okay so I think the main thing is that
right so in the case where the reference
is optimal the thing that should be good
according to the theory is still good in
the case where ref is suboptimal which
is the case we care about then lulz is
much better than everything else so in a
sense the empirical results match what
the theory says okay so can you do this
with bandit feedback yes you randomized
and then you do importance weighting and
you can ask me afterwards how to do that
so
so I should say this is like work with
lots of people
so in particular most of the stuff is
worked with huh who's the postdoc at
Stanford now she'll probably be on the
job market next year you should totally
hire her she's awesome
and also if you're really interested in
sort of like the the theory stuff so
Stefan was one of Drew Bagnall students
his thesis is awesome so if you're
looking for a place to get started with
some of the analysis stuff that's a
really really good place to look so this
is basically what I said and I will stop
and take any last minute questions
[Applause]
every question
as well I guess you can